the
china hua rong story is about stress
and turmoil at what is one of china's
largest managers of distress debt
in one of the country's most
high-profile corruption cases
the former chairman of state-owned china
huayra
asset management has been sentenced to
death
[Music]
lai xiaomin was convicted of receiving
more than 270 million
dollars over a decade the rare and tough
that was considered a particularly harsh
punishment
for corruption in part the swift
sentencing
was taken to be the latest sign of the
chinese communist party cracking down
on corruption particularly within the
financial
system and within the political system
we do have breaking news community from
this troubled asset manager here just
seeing her reports of the looming
restructuring of course playing out on
this and the
bond route there is deepening investors
concerned
about the finances of state-owned bad
debt manager
china hua rong and its silence isn't
helping i'm standing outside
china huarong's bond prices have been
incredibly
volatile over the last two months it's a
huge concern because this could test
china's debt ridden financial sectors
and the technocrats that run it as well
as all of the foreign banks and the
investors who have been
caught in between the drama
my name is rebecca chung wilkins i'm a
reporter and editor
for bloomberg news china credit team
china huarong is one of china's largest
distressed
debt managers it's a so-called bad bank
it has long been considered of systemic
importance
partly because its larger shareholder is
the ministry of finance
it was created in 1999 along with three
other asset managers
to try and deal with some of the bad
debt in china's economy so
those were things like bonds or loans
that companies had defaulted on
and they're considered essential to the
running of china's 54 trillion dollar
financial market so-called bad banks
help carry that risk on their own
balance sheet and help
curb all of that bad debt and remove it
essentially
away from the rest of the financial
system and that allows
china's other financial institutions and
its other banks to continue
with different kinds of banking services
that essentially help china's economy to
continue growing
[Music]
lai xiaomin ran china hua rong from
2012 until 2018. he was
also sometimes known as the god of
wealth
had a background in some of china's top
financial institutions
he had posts in the people's bank of
china as well as china's banking
and insurance regulatory commission
under ly xiaomi's leadership at china
hua rong
he expanded from the firm's original
mandate dealing with bad debts
into things like securities trading and
trusts he also turned to
the uh public debt markets to try and
fund
some of that expansion so under lysol
min
we also saw a massive expansion of the
firm's uh
bond outstanding bonds and those types
of debts were sold to both
mainland onshore investors as well as
global investors
overseas in the form of dollar bonds as
well as u.n
and hong kong dollar denominated bonds
laisamen was sometimes criticized
for just caring about short-term profits
and trying to go way beyond the brief of
what traditionally
a bad bank like
[Music]
he was actually charged with bribery and
taking illicit payments
in the course of the trial it came to
light that
had over the years collected a spate of
luxury cars
of luxurious apartments and expensive
watches
he had an apartment that he had renamed
the supermarket that was later found
to have cabinets that were full of cash
and a lot of this came to light during
the trial
some of which was televised and
became quite a public spectacle
he was executed earlier this year
the former board chairman of one of
china's biggest asset management
companies like xiaomi was executed on
friday
authorities said it was found that he
had
so wang zhang feng was um appointed
afterwards to take over the running of
china hua rong
and essentially to try and get it back
onto a
safe and steady footing that included
things like shaping up its financial
health and pulling back from some of the
riskier areas that lyceum in has
expanded into
under his leadership he was seen to be
certainly not as flamboyant as his
predecessor
but also brought in specifically to try
and introduce a
more serious and professional management
style
at china huarong 2.
concerns first flared at the company at
the
end of march when the firm failed to
release its 2020 annual reports
fundamentally what it means is that
investors and we
don't have a very clear insight into
precisely
how that cleanup has actually gone over
the last year
so investors suddenly started to worry
that there could be some issues with its
financial health
now that was then exacerbated by several
media reports
that there could be a potential
financial restructuring at china huawei
well obviously this has been a saga
now uh last week you know speculation
about a possible debt restructuring sent
its overseas bonds
down to record lows we've got another
ratings downgrade for juarong you've got
to wonder whether
this is a little bit of a delayed
reaction well as we've seen it has been
a rocky april for huarong
bond investors and we have seen those
notes continue to hit fresh lows and in
the wake
of this new york times report china
huarong's
bond prices have been incredibly
volatile over the last two months in
fact they've been
far and away the most volatile
trading that we've seen in the offshore
bond market and they've actually
weighed on the broader bond market as
well china huarong
is one of the bigger borrowers among
chinese firms at the moment has about
40 billion dollars worth of outstanding
bonds in the onshore and offshore market
about
4 billion of that needs to be repaid or
refinanced this year
when china huarang first started selling
a lot of offshore debt
it was considered by investors to be a
really
safe bet it was considered a
quasi-sovereign
it had an investment grade quality
rating
and the debt itself was really popular
among
many institutional investors and many
international
investors firms like blackrock allianz
and goldman sachs were all once buyers
of the notes
now the offshore investors are in a
little bit of a tricky
situation
[Music]
one reason why investors have become so
worried and so panicked about china
huawei
is the relative silence since they said
they would be delaying
their 2020 results we've really only
seen the company
and regulators come out once or twice
with public comments
to try and ease concerns regulators for
example have said that china puerto rong
has ample liquidity
and that its operations are running
normally
similarly we've seen some comments from
the company itself
also trying to reassure investors that
its liquidity is good
and that its operations are running
normally
however there generally has been
a kind of lack of information around
precisely what's going to happen at the
company what we do know
is that senior management has become
much more accustomed to meeting with
regulators and authorities and having
last minute meetings
and we also know that the company is now
providing a
weekly update on how its liquidity
conditions are going and
whether or not its operations are
running normally
in the short term china huawei is
expected to meet its debt repayments
and that's partly because warong has
been said to come to this agreement
where state banks will support meeting
its
debt obligations that come due through
august
on the other hand however the longer
term concerns about the fate of china
hwarong
persist
ultimately investors now are waiting to
see
whether or not beijing and authorities
step
in to provide a kind of guarantee
or a kind of bailout to china juarong i
think the assumption
generally is that authorities do not
want to see
a failure at hwarong which roils the
broader market
if we were to see fundamental and
painful restructuring of china huarong
or if we were allowed to see any kind of
payment failure
at a firm like warong which is
considered to be of
systemic importance which was backed by
central government institutions then
that really would change the way that
investors look at this market
[Music]
you